in what we've done so far we've ranged
over quite an area because just the act
of using the tea diagrams has forced us
to address lots of interesting and
profound questions over the years about
how compilers actually work so we've
looked at the fact that we think of our
programs being written in a high-level
language and the brain goes blurry we
neglect to think all the time that
although you they were written in C it
doesn't execute directly you have to
compile the C into binary so really your
beautiful program runs on a suitable
architecture in a suitable binary it has
an input it has an output then we
started looking at more advanced things
about saying well if that's how a c
compiler works why not write another C
compiler in C and then compile it with
the old compiler and I think we just
about emerged from that with brain
intact if you want to go back and revise
some of this stuff before catching up
with what we're going to do today I
would recommend the one which will put a
link out to home self compiling
compilers there's another one we put out
also on the unco problem which was this
business about is there a common
universal intermediate code there's more
of a consensus now than they used to be
and the LLVM system is a good example it
won the Turing ACM Award for not quite
for best intermediate code ever but you
know the reason I think that it became
less of a problem not totally sold
horrible but less of a problem thinking
about this the other night is that
actually over the years certain things
about computer architectures have
converged and moved together to
consensus and principally it seems to me
is the idea that your units of discourse
isn't just the bit it's the byte and the
idea of having you know 8-bit ASCII
characters fit into a byte of the idea
be know some glue two bytes together to
make a 16-bit entity or four and then to
make a very tuba and
that has become more and more and more
prevalent the reason why in some of the
other videos I've said oh you know there
was such massive differences between
machines there were in the 1970s I can
quote to you as a fact because there was
at the University of Nottingham working
on a machine with 24-bit words not my
addressed at all what did you put inside
you 24-bit words if you were mad keen on
characters four six bit characters how
did you dig them out from that word with
great difficulty the word address
machine would give you the whole word it
was your responsibility with bit shift
operations and the garden Spade more or
less to dig out for six bit characters
non-standard not 8-bit characters and
nobody saw well it's alright for IBM but
it's so much more expensive building by
stress machines but in the end it
prevailed and I do believe of things
like that about the fundamental way you
address memory and being able to sort of
put units together preferably in powers
of two not multiples of two
so right at the beginning I had a 24-bit
word Atlas had a 48-bit word deck
Tenzing had a 36 bit word and Seymour
Cray CDC had a 60 bit word all of those
are multiples of two but I don't think
any of them that I've just quoted are
powers of two and it really mattered it
turned out to have a power of two basic
unit beginning a bit a bit bytes so
anyway we've I use that to introduce the
idea of intermediate codes but we're now
I think in tying things up in a
situation to revisit that now and say
intermediate codes really are useful and
come into their own if you like with the
idea of wanting to port a compiler from
one architecture perhaps to a very very
different architecture what I call the
semantic gap between your high level
language and your program eventually
that runs on binary
is huge it's not so huge in sea you can
feel the assembler in the binary of
poking up through the sea but you start
trying to do a Haskell interpreter or
compiler and you'll soon discover that
this thing running down here is so to
speak miles away from the abstract stuff
you were writing up at the top so
everybody started saying don't we really
need intermediate codes to help us
bridge the gap
hence Zed code bytecode for Java all
these kind of things became discussed
more and more and more and I think I
once they said don't imagine it's always
fairly close to the hardware you could
end up in a situation where C is your
intermediate code beyond a screw stroke
you've got a C++ compiler started by in
its early days just making it produce C
but you know you can cope with what I
want to have a look at today is this
whole business of how do intermediate
codes help you port a compiler from one
architecture to another and you've got
to remember this in the worst case those
machines and architectures could be very
very different indeed I did an example I
think of running a C compiler on a PDP
11 in p mm binary whose
cross-compilation effect was to spit out
z80 binary which is very very different
how can you cope then with
cross-compilation and how does
cross-compilation lead you on to being
able to think about porting your
compiler not just producing code for a
foreign machine but in a way it's a
mountain invasion of the forest machine
and say I'm not just gonna push
boatloads of code over I'm gonna set up
a bridgehead we're gonna land and I'm
gonna set up a lot of my software tools
on the farm machine not just fling raw
binary at it
so let's start to discover a bit more
about this then but in order to get into
the details I have a great personal
mental expense made myself something
like forty or fifty T diagram blanks and
let us hope that those prove sufficient
for the task I just wanted to talk you
through this first of all as being the
basis for what we're going to discuss
and then I'll put it to one side but
I'll bring it back if I need to refer to
it again we are getting in to a land of
intermediate codes I've glued four
things to the page what are they well
these two that's not left or what I will
call source texts for your cross
compilation compiler porting efforts
what you're saying is from now on we
don't compile directly from H the
high-level language to produce binary B
in the code generator we do it in two
steps we have an H compiler written in H
producing I the intermediate code which
IC is not on this list let's add it I
equals intermediate code now on the left
at the top are the source texts for
doing this but if you consult the
previous things we have done on
compilation you will understand that
it's not directly those that we can use
because we can't directly execute H we
have to put these through an H compiler
and we end up with the binary executable
versions of them now a little bit of
extra notation here if you see at the
bottom for this executable be dashed I
use a single dash to mean the computer I
currently possess my old computer the
one I do all my work on if you see
things like B double dash that means the
new machine that I'm trying to port
things to so we'll eventually get to
that stage of getting stuff across and
you'll see B Double Dash is appearing
inevitably if you go this route your
compilation down to binary is now a
two-stage process it may be hidden from
you but it
to be there the other half you see is if
you're only going halfway to intermedia
code the other half of the journey is to
go from intermediate code down to
vulnerable binary for the other thing
there's your intermediate code
interpreter or compiler written in B -
running B - producing B - so I've
numbered these one two three and four
and eventually I'll come back and say
we've now created a new number three or
something like that what I'm going to do
in this whereas in previous episodes
I've talked about recoding a c compiler
to make better binary come out I did
that previously by calling it subscript
B for better but I've decided now that
use an asterisk if you see an asterisk
somewhere it means it's a better version
of what went before and I as
intermediate code so let's put that to
one side to be dragged back as and when
we need it when you write a program you
have in mind a certain input its execute
and it produces a certain form of output
and you're very happy and it all works
beautifully rather than rushing see down
here as I have been doing all along I'll
try and generalize it a bit say some
high-level language that you're
confident where than the views for ages
but all the while you know so this is if
you like user prog here you are you know
that H can't execute directly so you
rely on the fact that bootstrapped up
over several generations we just happen
to have an H compiler that runs in B -
and produces B - by slotting that into
there remember there's an implicit arrow
there that's H feeds into that one there
and the transformation done in this
compiler is to take the H and converted
into B - with a compiler that is now an
executable binary itself so the net
result of all that which will show up
here arrows is what that makes once
you've compiled is of course something
that as your treasured input and output
but is running H running on B - produces
B - so that is the binary executable
version of your program what happens if
your input and output was H itself can
you write a compiler in itself of course
you can what all this is about you want
to produce an H compiler we'll start off
by writing an H compiler in H so we'll
put this back to one side now these two
what happens if I were to say well I've
written an H compiler in age and it
produces B prime star what I'm saying is
I am fed up with plain old B prime
because it's slow and it's inefficient
and it was wonderful when I first did it
and actually this thing up here has been
bootstrapped up through being written in
assembler and heaven knows what C
previous episodes if that sentence
doesn't make any sense to you but now we
have got a situation you want to improve
the quality of your binary so here's a
bit of revision what you do is you say
okay I write a better C compiler better
in the sense of better quality binary I
feed it to the old compiler that we've
got working already which takes in H
runs on B prime produces B prime and
what does that send you up with answer
an H producing binary it's running on
old binary that's not super quality but
it's ok it doesn't crash it's a bit slow
just to end this little exercise off
before we get on to genuine porting
compilers you've got that and you
naturally then say well why not feed it
to itself again and if you get another
version of that feed one into the other
you can end up with H written in better
binary producing better binary and if
you look up self compiling compilers
that's exactly what we do so it's all
very well doing this simple-minded stuff
we take one great flying leap in our
compilers and require the code generator
to be able to get very low-level very
specific and yet be very
very tight and wonderful for all sorts
of different binaries for different
machines B - B Double Dash B Prime
that's hard so we've decided that
intermediate codes might be the answer
so how do we cope then using
intermediate codes just with this
business of improving your code how
would you do it well it has to be a
two-stage process no question about that
it has to be so this time I will an aged
compiler written in H and this time I am
going to make it produce better
intermediate code than ever before so
you see a think of it this way when you
upgrade a compiler you now got two
halves to upgrade do you want to upgrade
the H to intermediate code piece the
front end so-called or do you want to
upgrade the intermediate code
interpreter going down to binary the
back end you it's a mix and match you
can do either or both or in whatever
order you like but you've got to
remember it is a two-stage process
fortunately for me I have already
working an old compiler for H running on
B Prime
original machine binary and producing
ordinary intermediate code not super
intermediate code I've written a better
version of myself now and I'm upgrading
this front-end so we've got H written in
H producing I star better-quality
intermediate code in some sense and went
before but the old version of the
compiler I've been using for months now
just has H running on B prime producing
ordinary intermediate code not optimized
but it's good enough for compiling this
one the only thing that's different from
what we've got before is that we don't
directly end up producing binaries the
output we produce intermediate code as
the output so this first stage then will
get me the following H feeds into H
running on B prime produces I means that
this thing takes in H produces I star
and
is running on I okay fine
so we've kind of recompile the compiler
but we haven't gone far enough yet
and this is the the ball and chain
around your ankle when you go for
intermediate codes is you've got a
better thing but it is reliant on
running being able to cope with the fact
that's an intermediate code stage okay
that doesn't put us off what I've said
all along is that these are my key
source texts these are my executables
and what I'm pointing out now is if you
use intermediate codes you don't just
need a source end translator you need a
back end translator you need a thing
that says you know my system produces
intermediate code which I am the back
end that takes in intermediate code and
produces real binary there really will
run so I want one of those now to put
into my diagram this is what we're at so
far
let me gobble up yet another T diagram
and to say if I put in here what
everybody ought to have available to
them which is an AI producing B Prime
written in B Prime I can now that in
there like that and just look what
happens you've got your first staged
compilation it's doing wonderful things
but it's executing intermediate code and
maybe I have a test interpreter that
sort of to show you well that's kind of
working but in the end you want faster
more efficient code so you decide you
will compile your intermediate code into
proper binary and this kind of choice
between do I interpret it slowly and see
if it's working versus do I in the end
commit compiling it is the sort of thing
available in stuff like Java bytecode
and so on start off by interpreting
feels a bit slow but it's looking good
let's compile it now watch what happens
as you trace through here I goes in here
this is the intermediate code compiler
if you like now producing genuine binary
that shoots through there and what you
end up with
is H producing I star better-quality
intermediate code running on the prime
right well we're getting close there's
one final thing though that you need to
do what we've got ourselves now is a
situation where we've got a compiler
that takes in statements in H it is
running on B prime binary ordinary
unimproved binary but it does produce
better intermediate code we're now going
to pull the same trick that we've done
before in self compiling compilers the
only difference here though is we've got
this eye to cope with this time but the
principles and what we're doing are just
the same if I bring this one down to
stop my having to write out another one
we've now made a binary out of that feed
it to itself originally I started with H
I start to age I compiled it all the way
through to intermediate code as best I
could it's good quality intermediate
code now take that thing your executable
feed the original thing to itself and
look what happens the H goes in there
and produces I star so you end up with H
I start I star final stage coming up I
promise so that if you like when you're
serious mastery notions produces that
one final stage and I promise the
torture will end right now you might say
they're no big deal I can write an
intermediate code interpreter and check
out rough-and-ready it'll be slow but
check out whether everything works but
then somebody in the answer now come on
let's compile it it might go a lot
faster so if you remember item number 4
in our original toolkit was a thing that
takes AI and turns it into binary so I'm
gonna put one of those in place now for
that all the way through what will that
produce you don't forget we're starting
H producing good quality intermediate
code so that is what it produces but
what about here if you trace through
better quality intermediate code should
hopefully give you better quality binary
when you compile it so I can put down
here that this is basically if there
aren't too many suffixes and
superscripts there it's producing you a
h2i compiler but running on better
quality binary so one way in another
this is the new 3 because referring back
to our original map what i've said is
how can i improve that and i have
managed to improve it I've got better
quality intermediate code and better
quality binary it is improved but it has
been a fairly messy two-stage process
that's hidden from you but the idea of
that is to give you just the notion of
the fact that there is a penalty to pay
you have to have a two-stage process so
we've expended a lot of brain cells I
think between us now discovering how we
can improve our compiler which we did do
before in self compiling compilers
episode but this time it's different how
can you improve your compiler when
there's an intermediate code involved
and we've done it and we've seen exactly
how we can do it we feel weary or at
least I do but that is it any myself why
bother with intermediate codes it's just
producing more stages that we have to go
through well the answer us I think is
that it does make life more easy for you
if you say ok instead of improving
ourselves now within an intermediate
code context how about we say I don't
want better binary out of it I want
different binary for another machine so
we will find that the diagrams that I've
just drawn with some subtle adaptation
and me getting all tangled up probably
can be adapted for producing binary for
a completely new architecture which we
will be calling be double dash
we're now gonna find in this next one
we're doing is we're just changing the
rules slightly instead of beasts are
improved binary we're moving from B
prime to B Double prime so now if we
would know how to solve the problem for
three discs